sereine quand les transnationales qui va
générer des avantages économiques et
sociaux pour tout le pays le corridor
énergétique d'un yorkshire servirait au
pétrole de l'ouest
mais est-ce qu hydro québec par exemple
pourrait tirer avantage de ce corridor
on vante plus d'électricité à l'ouest de
la rivière des outaouais
regardons les faits savez-vous qu hydro
québec pourrait doubler ses exportations
d'électricité vers l'ontario sans
construire une seule nouvelle ligne de
transport
mais le premier ministre de l'ontario
d'oxford refuse d' importer plus
d'électricité du québec entre autres
parce que l'ontario power generation
investit actuellement des milliards de
dollars pour restaurer ses centrales
nucléaires une industrie qui emploie 18
mai ils ont parié en plus la société
ontarienne a investi des sommes
importantes pour acheter des centrales
au gaz dans le but d'accroître ses
revenus au manitoba la province a déjà
des surprises énergétique plus loin vers
l'ouest le transport de l'électricité du
québec coûterait des milliards de
dollars finalement construire une ligne
à haute tension à proximité d'un
pipeline ça augmente les risques de
corrosion donc de détérioration rapide
des tuyaux ça peut se faire mais ça
coûte plus cher et ça augmenterait le
coût du transport du pétrole de
l'alberta
[Musique]